how's it going bros my name is we're old
[ __ ] hell
that is a nasty I can't believe I put my
digging that hashtag relatable so now
we're playing with Catherine are the
girlfriend that we've been neglecting
this entire game Catherine can you hurry
the [ __ ] up
jesus [ __ ] christ mate it's almost
like you want to be cute
oh god we gotta make a bridge for
Catherine Keener can kinda be scared
Catherine K I can't drink it can tink
she okay
you use okay I do want to be free dammit
look how much more we have to climb
Catherine you're going the wrong way you
stupid oh my god is like you don't even
know how to puzzle worgen she got
Catherine has to make it - come on
Catherine get your [ __ ] together girl oh
god Catherine
good job Catherine you got yourself get
what that just happened
oh my god Catherine so disappointing
foxy
now Catherine holy [ __ ] Catherine you
crazy salable jesus [ __ ] christ mate
go camera we're almost at the top
started from the bottom now we're almost
at the top Catherine just keeps [ __ ]
being a [ __ ] block oh my god
Catherine wake up [ __ ] there thank you
follow me
Catherine come on oh my god Catherine
are you trying to piss me off cuz you're
doing a good job you're doing a great
job at that
Catherine can Catherine can hurry up
Catherine can almost there
Catherine you better not [ __ ] up now get
it high-five push taps ah you burned my
hand yes Jesus Christ me any man we made
it Catherine
we're gonna be all right we can make it
back through here make it back back to
where we were
let's go together
Catherine calls down you've got a child
to think about to mix everything it'll
all be okay well you mean you and me you
still thought about us then of course I
did I can't believe you anymore
oh [ __ ] and want to cheat on you I was
just confused about our future I guess I
snapped I'm sorry I know I did something
I can't undo I won't make excuses but I
realized something what did you realize
here you are to me I I understand that
now
please coward dump him come with you
chill I'm begging you're dead to me
I can't do it anymore Vincent you should
Catherine good no
how [ __ ] you just gotta believe in me
please Catherine I can't lose you not
like this
do i what that I wouldn't I wouldn't
really call that a Great Escape I would
more like call that a great that was
actually a great escape we could we
could have done a lot worse in life like
you
hey gold haven't seen you in a while
the [ __ ] what happened there that was my
level Malibu Malibu my [ __ ]
level pretty good yeah
proud of myself proud of you too doing
great it looks like the game is gonna
continue for a while I thought we were
like at the ending we still have the
[ __ ] nightmares huh what you came to
visit me in this room just
that's right where is she where's
Catherine Catherine what is going on
what's going on what's going on you
didn't see her nope
she doesn't seem to be here today look
we have to talk I'm breaking up with you
you've been cheating on me haven't you
do you admit it
but everything's good now just stop
babbling for a second
you haven't made a bit of sense this
entire time you're such a disappointment
you really don't remember are you still
dreaming you didn't answer your phone so
I came by
you were writhing around in your sleep
by myself yeah
so then I woke you up just now look
we're not free yes to treat you right so
technically we never cheated about what
yeah I finally understand now I realize
just how much you mean to my life so I'm
trying to save like I said about that
there's no baby how can that just turn
out
fix the cheating situation so
everything's supposed to be back to
normal right what's the problem just
just waste you're cheating on me with a
girl name's Katherine right the girl
with the same name as me
hold on there I was just confused I am
done with her okay I will never see her
again
plus I was gonna apologize to you it's
true so please
he doesn't really make it good Kaiser
look did you think I didn't notice of
course I noticed the prank calls must
have been from her what I'm actually
relieved to know that I'm not pregnant
to tell you the truth I knew earlier but
oh [ __ ] how can we tell you I felt like
you'd believe me it's dawn
of course if it wasn't for the pregnancy
I might not have decided to get married
come on I finally realized that I only
cared for Kathryn just just listen to me
I wasn't serious about her I don't even
think about her anymore you are all that
I need Kathryn just back there and the
dream so I snap out of it Vincent I came
here to break up with you
just yeah you should okay besides I
didn't come here to discuss that hit me
punish me whatever you like I'll do
anything for you no no that will change
anything
nothing wow there's nothing left between
us so don't call me you're serious can't
you tell I'm going well that was a good
ending
I brought you an energy drink I'll leave
it here so drink it well this is
farewell been an energy drink breakup
what the [ __ ] now no breakup sex what
what we never even got to see
well that was kind of a bummer ending I
don't think it's really over
you cheated on her [ __ ] what like
what do you expect it's not that
complicated you don't deserve to stay
with her
it [ __ ] took you let's do a nice
little saber nice a2q you cheated for
seven days okay
seven times men
you've haircut is so lame my hair is not
long enough it's been so long like five
years five years my shoes it's just my
mother's been calling me up and asking
how we're doing she's worried about me
and she knows I've got a career that
keeps me busy but I mean it's easy to
keep things like they are now there's
still a lot of questions month I'm
running really late I think I'm pregnant
I've been getting strange texts lately I
don't know they don't make sense it's
just creepy look Vincent you're not
hiding anything from me
are you hey do you think we'll work out
this isn't just because I got pregnant
right I can trust you
right I've been scared ever since I
thought I was pregnant I knew that it
was going to freak you out
I guess this is per well then goodbye
you see this weary feeling I can't
remember the last time I was alone in
the city man or a [ __ ] table what the
hell am I supposed to do Catherine
Catherine Oh huh bug um no I'll
definitely swing by probably later in
the evening yes sorry about that
Oh or Benson I can't believe this
what's gonna happen I'm soaking confused
and I just went in there some answers
you never dim saying you need
yeah she's not answering my calls
expected that dawn about that I broke up
with her at the bar yeah the next day
Katherine came to my room and she was
yeah but it was a dream it was a dream
bad man am I glad it was a dream it's
weird
I feel like it wasn't a tribute dude if
it wasn't a dream your ex-girlfriend
it'd be all over the news
after all you told me she stabbed the
other girl
our existence is gone why does it matter
why is he upset he broke up anyway
even the tiny pictures Oh No oh why do I
do
that's rough man
I use this phone to call her yesterday
we met split and that was that at the
bar where else you guys didn't see her
and no one else is seen Katherine you
saw me with her after that mess with her
you guys came by and tried to cheer me
up remember you don't remember that yeah
I remember that part but all I saw was
you looking pathetic by yourself by
myself yeah she was with me right I said
I didn't see her no I never even saw her
once right Jonny and Toby never saw her
either
I've only heard about it from you
numbnuts I thought you were doing that
to prevent Katherine from finding out
yeah
like I'd have the brains to do that
whatever look I only saw you yesterday
sure [ __ ] seems like any question my
sanity here man
you were saying before you guys were
just distracted right that would be like
what in a bar like that looks like hers
hey come on talk to me nobody sound
crazy as a long [ __ ] they're doing this
cellphone just glitch that's all and
last night you just weren't paying
attention right Jesus Christ is dreading
this on for so long I'm gonna ask Erica
now just come to the bar with me today
I'll show you that you're wrong
I mean we got we understand it by
ourself we don't need like a bunch of
people down back at the straight DP did
you and Catherine really break it up yes
Catherine with the K of course in the
entire time you were here you drank
alone right Toby that's exactly how I
remember it
maybe you're just spacing out from lack
of sleep after all you were pretty
messed up last night yeah you were
totally [ __ ] up dude I was just
dreaming the entire time I was here
these goddamn dreams every goddamn night
wait when did that dream start hey man
keep it down I'm only in this mess cuz I
cheated with her come on hey are you all
right yeah like that you were by
yourself just like that you were
dreaming you really messed up they're
gonna Corona
anyway pills alcohol nothing works for
glass yeah
whoa you guys are still having it oh no
now that you mention it Erica looked
like she was having a nightmare to
notice I don't remember anything though
you to America
I thought only men had that dream so
maybe gender doesn't matter huh I'm not
sure it's because you guys won't shut up
about nightmares the same thing with the
other customers - is it a weird chain
reaction
yeah it could be dreams we've been
having don't you feel like we're all
seeing the same dream really I can't
remember much but you know what it felt
like I was trying to get the hell away
from something like that
just climbing up and uh yeah mine was
like that too so what we're being shown
the same dream dumbass dreams are just a
reflection of daily stress stress from
what there's plenty of stress in
everyday life so cuz this jackass
started talking about it since I've been
hanging out with him so much he's
transferred some of his stress on me oh
yeah like he's messed up again
I'm going home I understand being
shocked but really screw someone up this
back you have an early shift tomorrow -
yeah you're right we should get going
hey Vincent we're gonna take off now
sure you're okay by yourself jury's
still out
he's not gonna tell us he met that girl
again later on as a idiot I wouldn't do
that I did see her last night thanks for
the [ __ ] home I'm just gonna drink
some so you guys can go on home what
okay fine fabulous then where are we
gonna have a [ __ ] nightmare again
aren't we dad damn it I thought we were
done with the night miss [ __ ] Nick that
mean we sure love rum and coke like in
eight days straight jizz rum and coke
right I was just thinking about it it's
only been a week since since when since
I met that girl here can life really
change this much just like that their
plot twists coming like a big fat plot
twist but maybe it's the dreams if you
don't get enough sleep your brain won't
function right and you start seeing
things different so you're saying that
you think she's an illusion too right no
I'm not saying that yes you are to be
honest I don't even know what's going on
myself [ __ ] a lot happened you're
probably just a bit confused plus you
have been drinking a lot lately
Hey sure thing maybe I'm crazy [ __ ] okay
that night it was like this I had a bad
dream the night before so I was here
drinking trying to forget they all left
early I stayed here then then she walked
in that night when she walked in the bar
there's a lot of people here but there's
suddenly my crowd that's right she spoke
to someone else besides me Oh Oh may I
help you
are you going on about no no don't play
coy with me I'm talking about Katherine
you saw her didn't you
I saw Vincent everyone else said they
didn't see her don't you think it's
crazy that only you did you're the one
that's crazy
Plus everyone in the bar is affected
soon make sense you saw I know he's
crazy keep shaking him some lunch you do
like that and we'll get people to talk
first yes I did indeed see she was blond
wearing provocative white dress like
lingerie yeah yeah that's the girl and
you saw her with me yesterday right yes
of course it's your preference isn't it
girls like her so then you admit it all
right
see he did see her
Jesus really you are just full of
surprises not only did you survive this
long whoa you figured me out
huh I must commend you for your
perception well I didn't really perceive
anything and sorry about the choking a
lot happened so I was a bit freaked out
tell me didn't see her there is no way
she does not exist that is the case
normal people can't see her after all
what tell me natural after all she isn't
from this res he's a demon from hell
it was rather unnatural wasn't it a girl
like her in a town like this either way
you don't need to worry I have given up
on showing you nightmares
swimming nightmares it was quite a sight
watching you run like the wind what are
you talking about he just still doesn't
remember she was here right her
Catherine uh-huh what is that face wait
you didn't rush what the [ __ ] is that
face I just I just wanted proof that she
really existed I knew that you saw her
you did right
I see the usual sir
can I ask you something what would that
be you see I thought that nightmares
were something that you see on your own
so could it be that that that someone
else can show you wonder I wonder my ass
pretty sure just heard you say you're
somehow involved in this what did I say
you were surprised I survived what does
that mean I didn't say that you said
well what if his eyes are like the red
thing that you see when you exit the
nightmare we go take him up let's see
the red ice
he has them
yeah who the [ __ ] are you stop you're
dealing with the desperate man now
thanks to you and your [ __ ]
monster it impedes the population the
rate of population growth is less than
optimal the hell are you talking about
so I have these hesitant gentlemen climb
that wait you're talking about the
nightmare you're the one behind that who
who the hell are you I have been given
many names by humans since ancient times
wasting a woman's time of greatest
fertility is a hindrance to the future
of the species so we separate these non
fruitful couples and redistribute the
women to men who can follow the natural
order you see okay so what you're just
killing men who have a partner that they
don't want to marry is that it what to
put it bluntly you think I'm gonna
accept your [ __ ] story please do not
worry
you won't see that young girl she
appears at will and seduces men under
the curse by appearing is their ideal
woman if you're going to sever ties with
a longtime partner what better way than
with a messy affair right do you
understand everything now when I get it
I get everything so in the end what am i
guilty of yeah if the girl doesn't exist
yes feels like cheating that it's
cheating right started this job
yesterday after all the reason you were
born was because we weeded out the man
who was misleading your mother I do
believe that was the case
you better stop [ __ ] with me if you
don't wish to believe that's fine
however it is a necessary evil having a
broken heart may be painful but you have
also earned your freedom plus you have a
fierce will to survive you should be
able to grasp happiness again soon
enough to me
she was already family I only realized
that after I was don't how pathetic is
that I really can't help you there this
entire situation is your fault right so
what are you gonna do about it
huh what yeah you're the one who cheated
my fault
sure as [ __ ] isn't mine you're the cause
of it all plus I was ready to get
married you got your wish yeah but that
was only due to your cheating on her
right besides it's too late to make up
with her now you don't decide that if
you really intend to push me here
tonight I will have to show you what I
can really do if that happens
when tonight will certainly be your last
are you prepared to die
prepare to die
what if you die damn you still alive we
came back since we're worried about you
let's drink some more man this is
getting so out of hand
what's wrong sorry I haven't finished my
chat with him yet you guys start the
party without me whatever you say just
don't go aggro you're drunk
don't worry we're just playing some
games here right yes that's right
there's no point screwing around with
you I'll let you off for now but in
return about what you were saying if I
am still alive tomorrow you're gonna
grab me my wish wait what are you saying
what are you saying divinity it's
impossible then you should have no
problem making that promise if you
really can't control the nightmares then
make this one the last it will be the
last whether you win or lose not just
for me everyone else it ends tonight and
not only that you're going to arrange to
have Katherine meet me here well I can't
do it I can't call her and it's not like
I can just text her very well
if you agree and I honor your conditions
it's really great and remember you'd
better keep your promise
got it oh hey Vincent are you sure about
this one wake of this [ __ ] is more
than enough and sorry to make you worry
back there but I got it in this not so
much with this jackass it's myself
anything can mix my ovaries explode
where did he go
is he just gonna keep drinking his rum
and coke who's gonna give me so weird I
love it
a little bit so much that guys never
finishing that beer is he all right a
rat a rat a rat we're gonna go to sleep
and then this can be a nightmare and I'm
a little bit worried because it's
probably gonna be really hard puzzles
and I'm great at puzzles I love puzzles
it's only eight Bocking yeah let's talk
to these guys really quick are you
grabbing boss actually you know what I
should probably in this episode here
leave a like for another video and I'll
see you in the next one thank you both
so much for watching as always stay
awesome bros